with the heat wave in the valley the
city of las vegas is reminding pet
owners about a new ordinance
that ordinance cracks down on people who
leave animals under the hot summer sun
hector mejia reports to get the message
across the city of las vegas got
together several agencies
along with a couple of dogs that are
famous on instagram
this year will be hippo the black labs
first time under the hot las vegas sun
make sure she gets air conditioning we
have actually a fan and misters outside
murphy the golden doodle plus this trio
of basset hounds
are helping the local fire department
remind people that it's never a good
idea to leave anyone outside
under extreme heat we experience one to
two calls a day
sometimes even up to 50. there's a new
misdemeanor ordinance in the books to
prevent animal cruelty
chief luis molina is head of the city's
department of public safety
what's changing is that if the
temperatures are expected to seat 105
degrees
and the pet owners are required to
provide misters swamp coolers
air conditioning they cannot leave the
animal in many cases dogs
outside in the heat in addition to that
molina says if the national weather
service sent
out a heat warning animals cannot be
tied outside
they have to be brought in if you see an
unattended pet inside of a hot car
dial 9-1-1 do not try to break into that
car
another reminder that pets can dehydrate
quickly
don't take them for walks during the hot
parts of the day
it's important to know the symptoms of
overheating in pets
which include excessive panting and
difficulty breathing
increased heart and respiratory rate and
drooling and mild weakness stupor and
sometimes and worst case scenarios even
collapse
we'll be posting the specifics on the
changes to the city of las vegas
ordinance on our website
8newsnow.com reporting in downtown
hector mejia
8 news now